[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
المانيا تتعهد باعتقال بوتين اذا زارها
تنفيذا لقرار الجنائيه الدوليه وروسيا
توثق جرائمك
المئات من الاحتياط يرفضون الخدمه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي والمحكمه العليا تحد من
صلاحيات وزير الامن
[موسيقى]
اتفاقنا امني بين العراق وايران والسوداني
يجدد رفضه ان تكون البلاد مسرحا للجماعات
المسلحه
المدعي العام في منهج يعلن التنسيق مع
شرطه نيويورك لحمايه المحققين من اي
تهديدات من انصار ترامب
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
تعهد وزير العدل الالماني ماركو بوشبن
تعهد باعتقال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين في حال قرر الاخير زياره المانيا
وذلك امتثالا لقرار محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه وقال بوشمان في تصريحات النشراتها
وسائل اعلام المانيه ان محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه ستتواصل مع الانتربول
لمطالبه الدول الاعضاء بالامتثال لمذكره
الاعتقال الصادره بحق بوتين مشيرا الى ان
المانيا ستطبق هذه المذكره وستحترم اختصاص
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
السفير الروسي لدى برلين سرجين تشايف اعلن
من جهته ان التصريحات غير المسؤوله التي
ادلى بها عدد من المسؤولين الالمان حول
تاييدهم لقرار محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
بتوقيف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هي
مصدر قلق بالغ
وكتبت البعثه الدبلوماسيه الروسيه في
منشور عبر التليجرام ان هذه التصريحات حول
قرار المحكمه السخيف للغايه على حد وصفها
تشير الى رغبتهم في تصعيد التوتر مع روسيا
هذا وتتوالى ردود الفعل الدوليه على اصدار
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره اعتقال
بحق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
جنوب افريقيا اكدت انها تدرك التزاماتها
القانونيه اذا زار بوتين جهانسبورغ لحضور
قمه البريكس المقرره في اغسطس المقبل وقال
المتحدث باسم الرئيس سيريل راما فوزا ان
جنوب افريقيا ستتعامل مع كافه الجهات
المعنيه بخصوص زياره بوتين المحتمله
في اول زياره له الى اقليم الدمبس منذ بدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا تجول الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في مدينه ماريوبلا
الاوكرانيه وتفقد عدد من المرافق فيها
زياره يقول مراقبون انها تحمل الكثير من
الرسائل
مترجلا يتجول بوتين في ماريوبول اشهر
المدن الاوكرانيه في ذاكره العالم هنا قاد
سيارته بنفسه وهنا وقف تحت نصب اوكرانيين
يعلوه على مرسي وقفه برسائل ودلالات كثيره
الرئيس الروسي اختار المدينه التي تشكل
رمزا للمقاومه الاوكرانيه وقلب اوكرانيا
الصناعي واقربها الى خط نار المعارك
المستعره منذ سنه ونيف الزياره المفاجئه
تعتبر الاولى لبوتين الى المناطق التي
استولت عليها روسيا منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وتاتي بعد يومين فقط من اصدار
مذكره توقيف بحقه وبالتزامن مع الذكرى
التاسعه لضم روسيا شبه جزيره القرن وفقا
لوسائل اعلام الروسيه فان سيد الكرملين
زار مدرسه ومركزا للاطفال في شبه جزيره
القرش عرض يقول مراقبه انه تحدي لمن اتهمه
بقتل اطفال اوكرانيا وترحيل الاف منهم الى
روسيا
الملك تاتي زياره قبل زياره مرتقبه لشي
جينج حليف بوتين الابرز وفي وقت يتكتل فيه
حلفاء كييف الغربيون لدعم هجومها المرتقب
في الربيع هجوم تقول انها تريد من خلاله
استعاده اراضيها المسلوبه ما بينما استولت
عليه موسكو وما تريده كييف وقف بوتي وقفه
قال فيها الكثير وان لم يتحدث رائد
المصطفى العربيه
اكثر المدن الاوكرانيه تعرضا للقصف الروسي
وحلقه مهمه في العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
باوكرانيا
بالسيطره على ماريوبل لاستطاعت روسيا
تامينا ما مر برين بين القرم ودونباس شرقي
اوكرانيا سيطر الروس على اكثر من 80% من
الساحل الاوكراني على البحر الاسود لقطع
نشاط اوكرانيا التجاري البحري وبالتالي
زياده عزلها عن العالم الخارجي الى جانب
خنق الاقتصاد الاوكراني فميناء
ماريوستراتيجي من اكبر الموانئ على بحر
ازوف وهي تحوي مصانع كبرى للحديد والفولاذ
وكانت تصدر الحبوب من اوكرانيا الى الشرق
الاوسط ومناطق اخرى
دفعه معنويه كبيره سقوط ماريوبل في قبضه
الروس سمح للكرملين باثبات ان روسيا تحقق
اهدافها وتحرز تقدما في ساحه القتال بينما
مثلت خساره ماريوبل ضربه كبيره بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين
معي لمزيد من المتابعه مكسيميا وهو استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه الطيران
الوطنيه سيد مكسيما اهلا وسهلا بك اي
رسائل تحملها زياره الرئيس بوتين الى
اقليم الدومباس تحديدا الى مريوبل وقيادته
السياره بشكل شخصي هناك
التحياتي لكم ولمشاهديكم
هذه الزيارات لها معاني رمزيه
وقام بهذه السيارات قبل ان ياتي رئيس
الصيني الى موسكو ومن المعروف انه ستكون
هنالك مفاوضات
فيما يخص الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه لان
الصينيه قدمت مقترحا
يحاولوا ان
احاولوا ان يحقق بعض التقدم في المفاوضات
القادمه لها معنى رمزي كبير فهي اكبر
مدينه تمكن الروس عليها منذ رابع وعشرين
من فبراير العام الماضي ودفعوا مقابل ذلك
ثمن كبيرا كما انها رمزيا خاصه بعد ان
اصدرت محكمه المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
قرارا او مذكره اعتقال
وهذه اول زياره لبوتين
على مدى تسعه اعوام لم ياتي الى دونسك من
قبل عاصمه ما يسمى بجمهوريه
جاء الى ماريوبل
لاسباب رمزيه لانه هنا ناحيه السياسيه هو
اكبر ميناء على بحر ازوت وهذا هو النصر
الوحيد الذي يدعيه بوتين
بحرا داخليا تابعا لروسيا لذلك اراد ان
يظهر لي المجتمع الدولي
بانه
كل ما عدم التنازل عن المريض ولكن في
حجماتنا عن وضع الدوله التي قد تبدا وتشان
في اتجاههم على بعد ثمانيه كيلو مترا
اقصدها الاوكرانيه المسلحه
وسيكون ذلك له اهميه رمزيه كبيره جدا
لاوكرانيا في تحرير هذه المدينه فالسيد
مكسيم اذا كنت اذا كنت تسمعني الا الا
تشير هذه الزياره الى ان الروسي يملكون
زمام المبادره تماما ولا شيء يمكن ان يؤثر
على قراراتهم لا قرار محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه ولا غيرها
فقط القوات الاوكرانيه المسلحه بامكانها
التاثير على بوتين لان
روسيا تمكنه
اعلنها كنتم بانها تابعه لروسيا بعد ان
اعلنت الضمه اربع مناطق اوكرانيه
ينطبق على المناطق الاخرى مثلا
بالنسبه لنا الاوكرانيين ليس مهما هذه
الخطوات الرمزيه
فنحن نسعى
لاعادتي هذه الاراضي وهي ليست لها اي قيمه
لروسيا خاصه
في الموقف الاوكراني المعروف نحن نعرف بان
هذه الحدود ستحددها على ارض المعركه
والمعارك وقادمه خلال فتره اغربي او الصيف
وبوتين ايضا يدرك ذلك وهو يحاول ان يظهروا
بانهم مسيقاتلوا مجلي المحافظه على
ماريوبل ليس كما فروا من خرسان عندما وصلت
قدراتنا اللوجستيه الى تلك المناطق
المجتمع الدولي يحاول يظهر بانهم لا يبالي
لان روسيا ولم تصادق
على ميثاق روما ولكن
حظ له دلاله رمزيه كبيره كما ذكرتم لان
اغلب المجتمع الدولي
الوقت اعتقد ان الفكره وصلت
العلاقات الدوليه في جميع الطيران الوطنيه
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
اعلنت مجموعه من جنود الاحتياط في وحدات
النخبه العسكريه والاستخباراتيه
الاسرائيليه في بيان لهم انهم لن يشاركوا
في بعض الواجبات المكلفين بها اعتبارا من
اليوم الاحد وذلك مع التصاعد حده
الاحتجاجات ضد خطه تغيير النظام القضائي
الذي تخطط له الحكومه وقال 450 متظاهرا من
جنود الاحتياط المتطوعين و200 اخرون
متطوعون وجنود احتياط من جهاز المخابرات
الموساد انهم يرفضون لاستدعاءات واداء اي
واجب
هذا وطالب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو مكتب المدعي العام
والسلطات المختصه بالتصرف بشكل حاسم ضد من
يحرض على قتله وعائلته والوزراء واعضاء
الكنيسه مشيرا الى ضروره وجود مناقشه
موضوعيه للاصلاح القانوني
لن نقبل الفوضى ومطالبه البعض بقطع الطرق
ومنظر الدماء في الشوارع وايضا تعرض
الشخصيات العامه للاذى لن نقبل بالعنف من
اي جانب اتوقع من قاده الشرطه تطبيق
القانون لمنع العنف وعوده الحياه الى
طبيعتها وان يتصرف مكتب المدعي العام بشكل
حاسم ضد الذين يحرضون على قتل الوزراء
واعضاء الكنيست وقتل رئيس الوزراء وعائلته
فالدوله التي تريد الحياه لا تستطيع ان
تتحمل مثل هذه الظواهر ولن نتحملها يجب ان
تكون هناك مناقشه حقيقيه وموضوعيه وعادله
للاصلاح القانوني
الى القدس ومزيد من المتابعه مع مراسل
العربيه زياد حلب زياد اهلا وسهلا بك هل
ما يجري داخل قوات الاحتياط زياد يمكن
وصفه بدون مبالغه بالتمرد على الاوامر ام
لا لا يجب تكبير الحجر وتكبير المساله
اكثر مما يجب
هذا قد يصل طالب الى هذا الحد في وقت قريب
الخشيه الاساسيه في اسرائيل بان هذه الكره
الثلج بدات
باليوم بعمليا عصيان عسكري من قبل المئات
وليس مجرد جنود احتياط عاديين هؤلاء من
وحدات خاصه يصعب تعويضهم في الجيش
الاسرائيلي عاده المهام الموكله اليهم هي
خلف الحدود بالاضافه الى طيارين وملاحي جو
ايضا يتطوعون في احتياط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي بهذا المعنى هذا يبدا الان
كمؤشر
بمقاطعه التدريبات ولكن بدون ان شك لا
يمكن التقليل في اسرائيل من خطوره هذا
الموضوع وفق مراقبين بان الامر قد يتحول
الى كره ثلج وقد يؤثر على معنويات وعلى
اداء الجيش الاسرائيلي من حيث المعنويات
والقدره القتاليه حتى هنا السؤال يعني منذ
ان بدات الازمه زياد وانت يعني خير من
تابع هذه الازمه قيل انه الازمه هي ازمه
سياسيه لن تتوسع لتصل الى الاجهزه الامنيه
والجيش ولكن الان الا يجوز السؤال ان
التشرذم
والازمه بدات تتسلل وبقوه الى الاجهزه
الامنيه والقوات الاسرائيليه وحتى جهاز
المساب
هذا صحيح جدا ولهذا يدق خبراء كثيرون في
اسرائيل ناقوس الخطر ويقولون بان الامر لم
يعد في اطار التحذير من ان تصل الامور الى
ضرب وحده الجيش الاسرائيلي ومعنويات هذا
الجيش بالفعل هي وصلت الى صفوف الجيش
للتذكير فقط قوات الاحتياط هي عماد الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الواقع ثلاثه ارباع هذا
الجيش ليس من القوات النظاميه وانما من
قوات الاحتياط مثلا سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
نحو 50% من الطيارين هم من الاحتياط حتى
ممن يشاركون في الغارات التي تسمع عنها
بين الحين والاخر في سوريا يلفظها ايضا
جنود احتياط او طياره احتياط وبهذا المعنى
الامور وصلت فعليا الى الجيش لهذا هناك
دعوات لتجميد هذه الخطه من قبل الحكومه
المشكله هي بان الاحتجاجات تسير
واصرار الحكومه على ما يسمى بالانقلاب على
نظام القضاء يسير بقوه هو الاخر زياد
عندما تقرا المحللين في الصحف الاسرائيليه
يعني ترى مصطلحات جديده جدا لم تكن
مستخدمه يعني لاول مره في تاريخها تواجه
اسرائيل خطرا وجوديا يعني مصطلح الخطر
الوجودي وانه اذا لم يتم حل هذه المساله
سريعا فان الحرب الاهليه اتيه لمحاله هل
هذه مبالغات ام لا هذا واقع الحال
عندما يقول وزير دفاع سابق مثل بينيجانس
هذا الامر يحذر من حرب اخرى بات يسميها
بدلا من حرب اهليه
وكذا ايضا الكثير من الخبراء وعندما يقول
يعني مدير وكاله الطاقه الذريه
الاسرائيليه السابق الذي انهى مهام منصبه
قبل فتره وجيزه عندما يقول بان الخطر لم
نعد بحاجه لايران لتهديد وجودنا لان الخطر
الدائم هو ما يحدث في داخل اسرائيل ولهذا
لا يمكن ان يعتبر الامر في هذا السياق
مبالغه لان الامور ذاهبه الى هذا المكان
الى يعني ان يتطور العنف الجزئي الذي نراه
في بين الحين والاخر في المظاهرات ان
يتطور الموضوع الى محاوله حسم في الشارع
هناك محاوله حسب في مكانين منفردين في
البرلمان حيث الاغلبيه لصالح نتنياهو وفي
الشارع والمشكله لبنيامين نتنياهو وحكومه
اليمين بانه لا حديث الان عن يسار ويمين
يعني هذا تسطيح للحاله في اسرائيل وانما
هناك اغلبيه من اكثر من 60% في الشارع
الاسرائيلي ايضا في عداد اليمين
الاسرائيلي ضد هذه الخطه من حكومه من
القدس مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي شكرا زياده
على هذه المتابعه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
20 عاما على حرب العراق واستطلاع يظهر ان
واحدا وستين بالمئه من الامريكيين لا
يعتقدون ان بلادهم اتخذت القرار الصحيح
بالغزو
اهلا بكم من جديد يتواصلوا اللقاء الخماسي
في مدينه شرم الشيخ المصريه بحضور مسؤولين
من فلسطين اسرائيل الاردن ومصر وذلك لبحث
تطورات القضيه الفلسطينيه واليات التهدئه
ووقف اي تصعيد محتمل خلال شهر رمضان
وذكرت مصادر للعربيه ان مصر ستطلب من
اسرائيل وقف اي عمليات عسكريه وامنيه خلال
شهر رمضان خاصه في مدينه نابلس والقدس
وتخفيف القيود لادخال البضائع الى قطاع
غزه
معي من شرم الشيخ لمزيد من المتابعه لهذا
الموضوع مراسل العربي احمد عثمان احمد
اهلا وسهلا بك هل رشح اي شيء عن هذا
الاجتماع وفي الحقيقه ما الذي استدعى عقد
هذا الاجتماع على جناح السرعه وحبر
اجتماعات العقبه لم تجف بعد احمد
نعم اهلا بك بالفعل كما ذكرت يعني هل هناك
سباق مع الزمن
لمحاوله للوصول الى الموافقه على حتى يعني
تهدئه لمنع اي تصعيد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه خلال شهر رمضان القادم هناك
خشيه بالفعل من ان الساعات المقبله
والايام المقبله قد تشهد المزيد من
التصعيد في المنطقه وبالتالي كان هناك
محاوله من كل الذين يجتمعون اليوم في شرم
الشيخ للاتفاق على عدد من العناوين
الرئيسيه للحيلوله دون هذا التصعيد من بعض
رؤوس العناوين التي يتم الحديث عنها بشكل
مباشر كما اسلفت في مقدمه الخبر اضافه على
تلك العناصر ايضا هناك اكثر من امور اخرى
تتعلق بالتفاصيل هي مساله وضع لجان امنيه
تنسيق ما بين الجانبين وايضا فكره الوصول
الى الوصول البضائع ودخولها وعدم وضع اي
ذريعه ان يكون هناك رد ردا على سؤالك هناك
خشيه من ان هناك ايضا عمليات تصعيد من
الجانب الفلسطيني في اعقاب اغتيال القيادي
في الجهاد اليوم في سوريا وهناك رغبه
بالعدم ان تكون هذه ذريعه لان يكون هناك
خلال الايام المقبله المزيد من اعمال
العنف والعنف المتبادل التي قد تستمر
وتتصاعد خلال شهر رمضان هناك تنسيق ما بين
الاطراف تنسيق امني اردني للضغط على
اسرائيل هناك ايضا حضور امريكي كبير في
محاوله للضغط على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وايضا هناك محاولات لان يكون هذا النجاح
في الوصول الى هذه التهدئه مقدمه لعمليه
لاحياء السلام مره اخرى عقب انتهاء الشهر
الكريم طيب اذا القاهره ستطلب من اسرائيل
كما بات معروفه في هذا الاجتماع وقف اي
عمليات عسكريه استفزازات خلال شهر رمضان
ولكن هل من مؤشرات تشير بان اسرائيل
ستستجيب لهذا الطلب المصري
يعني هناك رهان بان هذا الاجتماع والحضور
الامريكي الكبير في قد يلعبان دورا هناك
من يرى بان الساعات الماضيه كانت تشهد
انقسامات في الطرح وفي التحليل وفي الاراء
داخل المؤسسه الاسرائيليه عدد من
التصريحات التي خرجته يعني يتناقض بعضها
يطالب بعدم الالتزام كما ذكرت انت لم يكن
هناك التزام كبير حتى كما جاء في اجتماع
العقبه او ما تم الاتفاق عليه في اجتماع
العقبه في السادس والعشرين من شهر فبراير
الماضي على الجانب الاخر هناك ايضا
مطالبات او تهاجم هذا الاجتماع من قبل بعض
الفصائل الفلسطينيه ومن ثم هناك مصلحه
مشتركه للجميع لان يكون هناك احتواء
للموقف وعدم وضع اي فرصه للانقسامات داخل
البيت الفلسطيني او داخل المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه لان تكون تلك لعدم الالتزام
ومن ثم قد يكون هناك تصعيد تصعيد لو بدا
قد يراه البعض خطيرا وقد يستمر خلال ايام
الشهر وبالتالي هناك
رهان على ان يكون هناك
تنازلات تنسيق امني البحث عن حلول فيما
يتعلق ببعض المناطق في الضفه الغربيه
تحديدا في القدس وجنين ونابلس لعدم تكرار
المشاهد لعدم يكون هناك اي عمليات نعم
اغتيال وهذا هو التحدي الكبير اذا يكون
هناك التزام واذا نجح هذا الالتزام قد
يكون مقدمه الى ما هو مشهد قادم ما بعد
رمضان حول فكره استئناف عمليه السلام مره
اخرى من شرم الشيخ مراسل العربيه احمد
عثمان شكرا جزيلا لك على المشاركه
اعزائي المشاهدين هذه
صورتنا مباشره من بلده حواره الفلسطينيه
وهنالك عمليه توغل اسرائيلي كما
يقال لي من الاستوديو
وهنالك اصابه ايضا لمستوطنين
اسرائيليين في حواره جنوب نابلس اذا مراسل
العربيه يؤكد اصابه مستوطنين باطلاق نار
في حواره جنوب نابلس احدهما في حال
الخطيره وهذه الصور
هذه سياره
المستوطنين التي تعرضت لاطلاق نار في بلده
حواره بالطبع بلده حواره كانت على مدى
الاسابيع الماضيه مسرح لعمليات توغل
اسرائيليه ومواجهات احرق فيها المستوطنون
عددا من
المحال والبيوت والابنياء العائده
للفلسطينيين وبالطبع يبدو ان هذه
المواجهات مستمره خصوصا مع هذه المشاهد
التي نراها
وهذه العمليه ضد سياره كان يقلها مستوطنون
اسرائيليون بالطبع المراسل العربيه اكد
اصابه مستوطنين في عمليه اطلاق النار على
سيارتهما حالوا احدهم
خطره
قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله انه سيلتقي وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان قريبا مشيرا الى انه
تم اقتراح ثلاثه اماكن لعقد الاجتماع
واضاف وزير خارجيه ايران انه تم الاتفاق
مع السعوديه على زياره وفود فنيه
للسفارتين تحضيرا لاعاده افتتاحها وفيما
يخص اليمن قال عبد الله ان الازمه هناك
شان داخلي لكن ايران تؤكد على الامن
المستقر في المنطقه بالتعاون مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايضا قال ان ايران لن
تقبل اي تهديد امني يكون منطلقه الاراضي
العراقي
هذا ووقع العراق اتفاقيه امنيه مشتركه مع
ايران في حضور رئيس الوزراء محمد شياع
السوداني وذكر مكتب رئيس الوزراء العراقي
انه اكد خلال لقائه رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني علي شماخاني موقف بلاده
الرافض لان تكون الاراضي العراقيه منطلقه
للاعتداء على اي من دول الجوار واضاف
البيان ان الاتفاق الامني المشترك بين
طهران وبغداد يهدف الى التنسيق لحمايه
الحدود بين البلدين وتوطيد التعاون في
مجالات امنيه عده
[موسيقى]
في العراق 20 عاما تمر على الغزو الامريكي
للبلاد وعلى اسقاط نظام الرئيس صدام حسين
فكيف هو العراق اليوم وما الذي تغير في
تركيبته السياسيه
بعد عقدين من الزمن ما زالت تركيبه
السياسيه على حالها في العراق حتى مع
تغيير اتجاهاتها ومسمياتها الكتله
السياسيه الشيعيه المستفيد الاول من سقوط
نظام صدام حسين قبل 20 عاما وتكون حصه
الاسد من نصيبها في نظام ما بعد صدام فهي
اليوم باتت تمسك بمفاصل المشهد السياسي
برمته في العراق وتحت رقابه الحليفه ايران
وسط توازن هش ومتقلب محليا وحتى اقليميا
الصوره تبدو واضحه في الفضاء العام سواء
بصور رجال الدين العراقيين وغير العراقيين
المنتشره في كل الشوارع او من خلال احياء
المناسبات الدينيه التي كانت تقام بالسر
قبل عام 2003 هيمنه على الحياه السياسيه
بعد حرمان دام لفتره طويله من التمثيل
السياسي في ظل النظام القديم الذي اطاحت
به واشنطن حيث شرعت السلطات المؤق التي
نصبتها الولايات المتحده في بناء نظام
سياسي جديد مع حلفائها واقامه توازن هش
للسلطه القائم على المحاصصه وتوزيع
المناصب بشكل رئيسي بين الشيعه والاكراد
والسنه مع نسب صغيره لبعض الاقليات
الدينيه والقوميه
طيله هذه الفتره هيمنه الاسماء نفسها على
البيت الشيعي وهي التسميه التي اطلقها
المراقبون على الطبقه السياسيه التقليديه
من نور المالك وهادي العامري وعمار الحكيم
والقائمه تطول كما ان اساسيات النظام لم
تتغير الى حد كبير فالقواعد التي ارسلتها
النخبه في عام 2003 وحتى 2005 ما زالت
تحكم الحياه السياسيه حتى الان
تضارب المصالح والبحث عن النفوذ داخل
اركان البيت الشعير دفع الخلافات للظهور
الى العلن لتبلغ ذروتها في اعقاب
الانتخابات التشريعيه الاخيره في عام 2021
لتتحول بعدها الى صدام مسلح على اسوار
المنطقه الخضراء في اغسطس 2022 بيوم من
القتال الدم في بغداد وما زال معظم
العراقيين الذين ولدوا بعد عام 2003 يمنون
النفس بدوله يحكمها القانون لينعموا
بخيرات هذا البلد الذي لم يعرف طعم
الاستقرار منذ زمن ليس بالقصير
وتزامنا مع الذكرى العشرين للحرب على
العراق افاد استطلاع اجراه موقع اكسيوس
ابسوس الامريكي ان واحد 61% من الامريكيين
لا يعتقدون ان بلادهم اتخذت القرار الصحيح
بحرب العراق بينما يعتقد 36 من الامريكيين
ان بلادهم كانت محقه في هذه الحرب كما بين
الاستطلاع ان واحدا وثلاثين بالمائه فقط
من الامريكيين يعتبرون ان حرب العراق جعلت
امريكا اكثر امانا
وبحسب الموقع امضت القوات الامريكيه ثمان
سنوات في حرب العراق وقد قتل خلالها نحو
200 الف عراقي الى جانب ما يقرب من 5000
جندي امريكي
وقد كلفت الحرب الولايات المتحده نحو خمسه
تريليونات من الدولارات
السابع عشر من مارس 2003 جورج بوش يمهل
صدام حسين 48 ساعه لمغادره العراق
التاسع عشر من مارس 2003 جورج بوش يعلن
الحرب على العراق
العشرون من مارس 2003 بدء الغزو الامريكي
للعراق
التاسع من ابريل 2003 دخول القوات
الامريكيه بغداد واسقاط تمثال صدام الاول
مما مايو 2003 جورج بوش يعلن انتصار
امريكا في العراق
الثالث عشر من ديسمبر 2003 اعتقال صدام
حسين
السابع عشر من يناير 2004 تقرير يقول
المعلومات عن اسلحه الدمار الشامل جميعها
تقريبا مغلوطه
من من نوفمبر 2004 هجوم امريكي على
الفلوجه بمشاركه نحو عشره الاف جندي
الثاني عشر من يناير 2005 البيت الابيض
يعلن عن انتهاء عمليات التفتيش دون العثور
على اسلحه الدمار الشامل
الثلاثون من ديسمبر 2006 اعدام صدام حسين
الشنقن
الحادي والثلاثين من اغسطس 2010
اوباما يعلن نهايه المهام القتاليه
الامريكيه في العراق
السادس من يوليو 2016
تقرير لجنه تشيلكوت حول حرب العراق يقول
المزاعم الاستخباراتيه حول تطوير العراق
لاسلحه الدمار الشامل كانت معيبه
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع اذهب
الى بغداد ينضم اليه من هناك الباحث في
الشؤون السياسيه والامنيه زياد العرار
زياد اهلا وسهلا بك ربما سؤال وجداني اقرب
منه سياسي خصوصا في مثل هكذا مناسبات بعد
عشرين عاما على هذه الحرب هل تغير العراق
نحو الافضل ام لا انحدر نحو الاسوا ام
الامر سيام
شكرا تحيه لحضرتك والمتابعين الكرام سيد
الكريم لم يتغير شيء في العراق فقط نظام
الحكم هو الذي تغير يعني من نظام شخصي
نظام حزبي لشخص واحد الى نظام يقوده عده
اشخاص وزعامات نعم تغيير على مستوى
الاداره السياسيه لكن على واقع الحال
العراق ما زال يعيش في اسوا حالاته رغم كل
المحاولات التي ابدتها القوى السياسيه لان
تذهب بالعراق باتجاه جديد يعني الوضع
الاقتصادي واضح في العراق الان والارتفاع
السعر الصرف والان نحن في عام 23 والمواطن
العراقي ينتظر دعم الحكومه للسله الغذائيه
لو كانت الظروف جيده ومستقره بشكل اكبر
لكان العراقي يعيش الان في بحبوحه لو
استطاعت القوى السياسيه ان تذهب الى بناء
دوله حديثه وجديده برؤيه جديده بعيده عن
المنازعات بعد الاجتياح الاميركي وتغيير
نظام صدام حسين لكان الوضع مختلف لكن
مجموعه نقاط في اولها والخلاف السياسي
والتدخلات الخا والعصابات والارهاب ارهاب
القاعده ارهاب داعش ارهاب المجاميع
المسلحه ادت الى اننا بعد 20 عام لا نشعر
بالتغيير الكبير نعم التغيير في النظام
وفي طريقه الدستور المسمى والمكتوب لكن
اجراءات فعليه نحتاج اعتقد الى ثوره
داخليه لدى القوى السياسيه حتى تنتفض على
نفسها وتذهب الى بناء الدوله وهذا اللي
نتمناه استاذ زياد سؤال استطرادي اذا هل
كان يمكن تجنب هذه الاخطاء او الخطايا ان
صح التعبير التي ارتكبت بحق العراق ام لا
هذه الخطايا كانت مقصوده
يعني من الجانب الامريكي واتحدث بصفه شاهد
متابع للاحداث كانت مقصوده بكل تفاصيلها
منذ القرارات الاولى وحتى ابدال الحاكم
الاول الاتيان ببريمر يعني
هذه كلتها كانت مقصوده وكانت وكان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تريد
للعراق في تلك الفتره ان يستقر اتحدث من
2003 الى 2005 الى ان ارادت ان يبقى
العراق في دوامه اما القوى السياسيه فلم
يكن بمقدورها وباعتراف كثير من قاده
المشهد السياسي قالوا لم نكن مستعدين
للحكم بعد هم اعترفوا يعني انا انقل
لحضرتك اكثر من كلام قالوا لم نكن مستعدين
للحكم والولايات المتحده الامريكيه يعني
باقتتنا بالطريقه التي تريد ان تحكم بها
العراق طبعا القوى السياسيه معارضه وبقت
في عقليه المعارضه الان بدات تصحى وتتحدث
عن اخطائها علها تذهب باتجاه تصحيح تلك
الاخطاء الاخطاء المقصوده من الجانب
الامريكي ومفروضه من الجانب والقوى
السياسيه العراقيه طيب استاذ زياد منذ
عشرين عاما قيل ان العراق سيصبح ساحه
للمشاريع الامريكيه ومحطه امريكيه في
المنطقه هل فعلا حصل ذلك ام لا العراق
تحول الى اكثر من ساحه امريكيه تركيه
ايرانيه الى اخره حدث ولا حرج
وايضا ارجع لك باعترافات يعني كبار رؤساء
الاجهزه الامنيه بانه احنا عندنا اكثر من
30 الى 50 جهاز استخباري دولي كبير كان
يعمل في العراق الى وقت قريب يعني يمكن
الى انه الى عمليه التحرير من داعش كانت
الاجنده واضحه الاجنده الخارجيه ليس
العراق ساحه للمخابرات او للاجندات او او
للرؤيه الامريكيه فقط ايران امريكا المحيط
الاقليمي المحيط الدولي عبث في المشهد
العراقي وكل من لديه حسابات وتصفيه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه جاء ليزرعها
في العراق وبالتالي دفع العراقيون ثمنا
كبيرا يعني باهظا حتى التقرير اللي تحدث
يعني تحدثت به تقرير جيد وواقعي جدا فقط
ويعني اضع علامتين استفهام امام الاعداد
اللي مذكوره 5,000 جندي امريكي فقط قتلوه
بالعراق هذا غير معقول طبعا و200 الف
مواطن عراقي قتلو ايضا هذا غير معقول ما
قتل هو اكثر بسبب الحرب التي كانت موجوده
ودائره على الا راضي العراقيه
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من بغداد الباحث في
الشؤون السياسيه والامنيه زياد العرار
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
[موسيقى]
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
تظاهرات جديده في فرنسا في خضم ازمه
سياسيه واغلاق مصافي التكرير يلوح في
الافق بعد انضمام نقابه عمال توتال
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه حذر المدعي العام في مدينه منحه
من التعرض للمحققين العاملين في القضيه
الخاصه بالرئيس الامريكي
وقال المدعي العام انه لن يتسامح مع اي
محاوله لترهيب المكتب او سياده القانون في
نيويورك مشيرا الى انه ينسق مع اداره شرطه
المدينه لتقديم الضمانات اللازمه للمحققين
ياتي ذلك بعد ان طالبت ترامب انصاره بدعمه
لانه سيتعرض لمحاوله اعتقال يوم الثلاثاء
وذلك على خلفيه قضيه دفع اموال للممثله
الاباحيه ستورمي دانيلز مقابل الصمت عن
علاقه جمعتهما ابانا انتخابات الرئاسه عام
واصل معارضوا اصلاح نظام التقاعد في فرنسا
التعبير عن غضبهم وسط توجه الى اغلاق
مصافي التكرير وقال متحدثون باسم شركه
توتال الفرنسيه للطاقه ان 34% من العمال
التشغيليين بالمصافي
والمستودعات اضربوا عن العمل تزامنا مع
استمرار الاحتجاجات على خطط الحكومه لرفع
سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
واعلنت الكونفدراليه العامه للعمل ان اكبر
مصفاه في البلاد التي تقع في نورماندي
بشمال غرب فرنسا بدات بالتوقف عن العمل
لكن لا يتوقع ان تسبب نقصا فوريا في
الوقود في المحطات الفرنسيه
وقد تتخذ الحكومه اجراءات في حال اغلاق
هذه المنشات لتجنب نقص الوقود وفق وزير
الصناعه الفرنسيه
ومع مواصله معارضي اصلاح نظام التقاعد في
فرنسا التعبير عن غضبهم في مسيرات جديده
تراجعت شعبيه رئيس الفرنسي
بشكل كبير في مارس الى 28 بالمئه وهي
الادنى منذ نهايه ازمه السترات الصفر عام
وبحسب استطلاع النشرته صحيفه لجورنالدو
الفرنسيه شملت الفا 1928 شخصا فان 70% من
المستطلعين غير راضيين عن اداء ماكرون
الى باريس الان ومزيد من المتابع مع مراسل
العربيه فادي دهوك فادي اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد من عندك في هذه الاوقات مع
العلم ان اليوم هو يوم عطله يوم الاحد في
فرنسا
اهلا طالب نعم اليوم هو يوم عطله في فرنسا
لكن هناك تظاهره خرجت قبل قليل في احدى
المراكز التجاريه في ضاحيه ساندوني هذه
التظاهرات تخرج باتت تخرج بشكل مفاجئ وهي
سريعه جدا يخرجون في مراكز للتسوق وايضا
في الشوارع حتى الان هنا في ساحه
الكونكورد على مقربه من البرلمان كما ترون
هناك حشد امني لحراسه هذه المنطقه هي تقع
في المربع الامني للعاصمه باريس تحسبا من
خروج التظاهرات طبعا الشرطه قامت بتمديد
حظر التظاهر في هذه المنطقه اليوم بعدما
اصدرت قرار حظر التظاهرات في هذه الساحه
يوم امس ايضا هذه الساحه شهدت مواجهات
عنيفه جدا على مدار يومين منذ يوم الخميس
الماضي وهو الموعد الذي استخدمت فيه
الحكومه الماده
49,3 لتمرير مشروع قانون رفع سن التقاعد
وهنا في الساحه نرى عبارات كثيره واثار
للمتظاهرين تركوها مثل هذه اللا
في الساعه في اشاره الى ان هذه المساله
اصبحت عاصفه ستكون ضد الحكومه في اطار
الاحتجاجات طبعا هناك ايضا مساله
الاضرابات التي تحدثت عنها في مستودعات
تكرير النفط هناك عدد من المستودعات بدات
تفكر في ان تقوم باجراء اضرابها ابتداء من
يوم الاثنين واحد الثلاثاء المقبل سيستمر
هذا الاضراب ليومين لكن حتى الان لم يتخذ
القرار بعد ايضا هناك مساله اضراب
المعلمين يوم غد سيكون اليوم الاول في
امتحانات الثانويه العامه وهناك حاله من
عدم اليقين ما اذا كان المراقبون سوف
يتوجهون لمراقبه هذه الامتحانات بالاضافه
الى ان عدد كبير من المنظمات الطلابيه
يدعون الى اغلاق الثانويات ومنع تقديم
الامتحانات فيها ايضا هل يمكن القول ان
الايام المقبله ستشهد مزيدا من التعزم
والتصعيد في الشارع ام لا الحكومه تراهن
على الوقت انه مع الوقت النقبات والاتحاد
العماليه ستنصاع لهذا القرار عاجلا ام
اجلا
الحكومه تراهن على مساله الوقت لكن هذا
الاسبوع سيكون حاسما جدا ابتداء من يوم
الغد سوف يكون هناك تصويت في البرلمان على
مذكره لحجب الثقه من الحكومه الفرنسيه هذه
المذكره او هم طرحت مذكرتين واحده من قوى
اقصى اليمين بزعابه مارينلوبين والاخرى من
كتله النواب المستقلين ستدعمها كل الاحزاب
السياسيه وايضا ابدت كتله مارين لوبين
استعدادها للتصويت عليها لذا المشهد ما
يزال متوترا وهناك تراقب كبير ايضا سيكون
هناك يوم تعبئه وطني في فرنسا في الثالث
والعشرين من هذا الشهر سيكون يوما للاضراب
والتظاهر تنظمه النقابات والاحزاب
اليساريه وايضا قد تنضم اليه الحركه
الطلابيه التي بدات او هي التي تقوم بهذا
الحراك منذ ثلاثه ايام وتخوض مواجهات
عنيفه مع الشرطه يوم امس كان هناك تظاهرات
كبيره في العاصمه باريس واسفرت عن اعتقال
110 اشخاص بحسب ما اعلنت وزاره الداخليه
في تحديث جديد للارقام اليوم هذه
التظاهرات بدات تخرج في معظم المدن
الفرنسيه وايضا في مناطق صغيره جدا ونائيه
الكل يتظاهر ضد هذا القانون والمشهد متوتر
وفي تراقب شديد في العاصمه من باريس مراسل
العربيه فادي دهوك شكرا جزيلا لك فادي على
هذه المشاركه
عمليات دمويه تبنى المسؤوليتها تنظيم داعش
اخرها عمليه انتحاريه قتل فيها حاكم
مقاطعه بلغ الشماليه
ما هو حجم عناصر داعش افغانستان وهل
التنظيم يشكل تهديدا على الامن هنا نتابع
خالد جدران متحدث باسم قياده الامن في
العاصمه كابول يعترف بان عناصر من تنظيم
داعش اختفوا في البلاد بعدما دخل الطالبان
العاصمه وقامت بكسر ابواب السجون التابعه
للنظام السابق التي كان يقمع فيها عدد من
معتقل التنظيم
قوتنا الامنيه جاده في التصدي لجميع
العناصر الشريره التي تهدد الامن وتضايق
المواطنين نحن نقوم باحتقالهم وقتلهم
حيثما ظهرنا بهم
مهاجر فراهي وكيل بوزاره الثقافه والاعلام
للافغانيه يؤكد عمليات الدواعش بين حين
واخر ويصف اياها بانها متقطعه لا تؤدي الى
زعزعه الامن بحسب تعبيره
في بلد يعيش فيه اربعون مليون شخص من
الطبع ان تحدث فيها عمليه امنيه خلال شهر
ولن نستطيع وصف الوضع بان الامن انعدم
تماما فان مثل هذه العمليات قد تحدث في
جميع بلاد العالم
في عمليات مضاده نفذتها القوات الامنيه
خلال شهر فقط قتل ابو عبيده الكشميري امير
داعش لشبه القاره الهنديه والقارئ فاتح
مسؤول العمليات القتاليه لداعش فرع خراسان
على الرغم من عمليات دمويه يقوم بها تنظيم
داعش في البلاد فان السلطات في كابول لا
تعتبر التنظيم تهديدا خطرا وذلك لان عناصر
التنظيم لم تستطع السيطره حتى الان على
شبر من الاراضي الافغانيه عبد الانادر
العربيه كابول ظهرت لقطات فيديو غرق متحف
على رصيف في المنطقه الساحليه لاقليم اورو
في الاكوادور بشكل كامل بعد انهياره خلال
زلزال قوي بلغت قوته 6.8 درجات على مقياس
ريختر وذكرت وسائل الاعلام محليه ان
الموقع المعروف باسم متحف ويرتو بوليفار
البحري شيد قبل اكثر من 60 عاما ويضم ما
لا يقل عن خمسه الاف قطعه اثريه
بحريه
نشاط الخامسه المفصله من العربيه انتهت
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]